This is Euglena ehrenbergii, and as you can
see, it is a bit of a shapeshifter.
It’s not just changing its shape though…it’s moving.
Across the surface of this unicellular eukaryote,
a series of strips made out of protein run
the length of the cell, working with a system
of molecular tubes to drive this cellular
contortionist around in a form of movement
known as metaboly.
Those strips create a ridged surface along the plasma membrane called the pellicle, this is the
structure that unites the otherwise incredibly diverse set of organisms called euglenoids.
Euglenoids are mostly found in freshwater,
where many species get their food by engulfing
it through phagocytosis.
Millions, or maybe even a billion or so years
ago, the thing that got engulfed was a photosynthetic
green algae.
This marks a major division.
Many euglenoids, like this peranema, don’t have chloroplasts.
Instead, these non-photosynthetic species
rely on feeding mechanisms like phagocytosis
or osmosis.
But the euglenoids we’re going to talk about
today are the ones whose ancestors not only
ingested the green algae, they took on the
algae’s chloroplast and the rest of the
photosynthetic apparatus, evolving the ability
to make their own food in addition to consuming
nutrients from their environment.
As we mentioned earlier, the common link between
euglenoids is that striped surface called
the pellicle.
Other than that though, euglenoids can look
pretty different from each other.
The most common shape among Euglenoids is
this sort of elongated almond shape, where
the end comes to a tapered point.
Then there are these Monomorphina pyrum, whose
bodies are more rounded and have a clearer
tail coming out at one end.
You can see Monomorphina pyrum here as well,
along with Phacus tortus.
Almost all Phacus species have this sort of
flat, diamond body, resembling a leaf, and
some—like this Phacus helicoides—can twist that leaf into an amazing and beautiful corkscrew-like structure.
Phacus species do have a pellicle, but they are rigid and can’t actually engage in metaboly,
that shape-shifting method of locomotion we saw in the beginning that is so common to
euglenoids that it’s also called euglenoid
movement.
In general, the flexibility of euglenoids
corresponds to the number of protein strips
in its pellicles.
Species that are less rigid and thus more
likely to use metaboly have more strips, while
more rigid species have fewer strips.
So you might be wondering how these rigid
species get around if they can’t rely on
wiggling their bodies to different places.
The answer is simple: flagella.
All photosynthetic euglenoids have two or
more of those hair-like structures that they
use to move, even if they are capable of metaboly.
The flagella are a little hard to see…if
you squint, you might see them here towards
the front end of the cell, which is also where
you’ll find that distinct reddish spot that
looks kind of like an eye.
That red spot is, appropriately enough, the eyespot, though it doesn’t actually see
Instead, the eyespot works as a sort of “shading device”, that along with photoreceptive
proteins at the base of the flagella, tells
the cell where it can find light to drive
photosynthesis.
Now, despite their ancient green algae origins, the chloroplasts in photosynthetic euglenoids
are a bit different from their ancestral counterparts,
particularly in how they store their energy.
Green algae make a starch that is stored in the chloroplast for their later energetic
needs, because the sun never shines all day.
but euglenoids produce a different
carbohydrate stock called paramylon that is
kept in the cytoplasm of the cell instead of in the chloroplast.
Different euglenoids keep their paramylon
stored in different shapes, ranging from small
discs to larger rods.
As this euglenoid turns, you can actually
see its paramylon bodies. It’s those oval ring structures.
And when the cell uses the paramylon for energy,
those rings will become thinner.
Of course, as we’ve seen in other episodes,
things in the microcosmos can get tough, so
some euglenoids build their own defenses.
This is Trachelmonas.
And I should say here that I am fumbling through some of these pronunciations so don't take them as gospel.
It's encased in a protective structure called the
lorica, a sugary matrix that the cell produces
when its young.
The lorica starts out as a softer, more flexible
covering.
But over time, it picks up minerals like iron
and becomes increasingly solid.
You can tell that compared to the other very
green euglenoids we’ve shown, this little
guy is more on the yellowish side.
That color actually comes from those embedded
minerals.
These Euglena sanguinea are demonstrating
another use for sticky encasements under stress.
These cells have entered what is called the palmelloid stage.
On the right side of this clip, you can see
four cells enclosed in a clear membrane, but
when this little clique was started, it was
originally just one cell that had lost its flagella
and enclosed itself in a capsule of its own
making.
In time, that one cell divided into two, and
then those two cells divided into four.
When conditions are right, these cells
can leave the capsule and reform their flagella.
Euglenoids have had a very, very long time
to evolve, and as we’ve seen, the things
that they have evolved into are diverse—so
diverse that, combined with the varied shape-shifting
abilities of its member species, euglenoids have proven challenging, both to identify and to classify.
In the past few centuries, attempts to categorize
them have resulted in their inclusion with
animals, with plants, and with protists, as well declarations of their own kingdom.
The microscope is a powerful tool, but this is where molecular tools like gene sequencing
take over, helping scientists better understand just how the species of this vast group are
related to each other and to everything else.
And even as these threads of evolution get
untangled and old questions get answered,
there will only be more questions to ask and opportunities to wonder.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to come back to see more of the beautiful, weird world of the micro
there's probably a subscribe button that you can click on.